joining us on the phone is a man that
won a couple of Super Bowls your hair
I'm on the radio and the Giants
broadcast as well Carl banks pleased and
actually very happy to have him on the
line with us now hi Carl how are you sir
I'm great Andrew I I do apologize
because I actually went Geno Smith on
you I was scheduled for 140 and it's now
240 were you also Carl at the movie
seeing gone girl no but there's a really
great burger place right around the
corner from my office called black iron
burger I took my designers to but hey
I'm here I am so happy to be here and
we're happy Carl that you are here and
we want to talk giants and eagles but
you mentioned it you mentioned Geno
Smith so I've got to go there have you
ever heard of a player and a quarterback
at that going on the road and the day
before the game going to a movie is that
something that Phil Simms whatever do um
and recorder that it'd be very rare I
mean if you were two days before the
game yeah that happens um you know what
things do happen but if your quarterback
it's not supposed to happen to your
quarterback is the guy who comes early
stays late you know he's the leader he's
the general so it was just kind of it
was kind of disappointing when I heard
that he missed a meeting like
quarterbacks don't do that so I think it
speaks to a level of maturity to and
probably a little bit of the culture
that's kind of maybe a little too
loosey-goosey thinking that you know
guys would take responsibility and be
accountable for their actions Carl don't
a linger on this but can you be a team
leader if you do that and you don't get
benched um I want to say no but you can
be but you know leadership is something
that's done by example as well as your
your play on the field and certainly his
example hasn't been what you want your
quarterback to be but it's kind of you
know kind of
symbolic of what they're going through
right now you know it's kind of a you
know kind of a directional directionless
environment right there and they've
really got to all get on the same page
and just focus and you know it has to
start with your quarterback situation
and you know you listen to michael vick
talk and you know his words he said
we're kind of misinterpreted but he's he
was brought there because he's a veteran
of Marty morning work system for him to
even say he wasn't prepared is even
worse because he know he knows the
system right right you know so it's all
kind of weird and I think you know and I
think the world of Rex Ryan I think he's
one of the brightest defensive minds in
football but he's got a really kind of
get a grip on what's the entire culture
of this team right now he just can't be
single-minded right now every he's got
to be all hands on deck well let's be
single-minded on the Giants cuz that's
why we have e on the Giants play the
meals this week and listen I think if
there was ever a lesson that the
preseason truly doesn't mean anything I
think case in point here it's the Giants
they were awful i think we all agree in
the preseason particularly on offense
those offensive numbers have improved
every single week how much room for
improvement is there is this Giants
offense Carl the offense we're going to
see the rest of the year it doesn't get
better than this no I think it gets
better because as a and you can see ly
feeling more comfortable with his
offensive line they're really starting
to play as a clean unit but I think it
does get better because you have Odell
Beckham who now is saying to any
defensive coordinator in football well
if you double cover our tight end if you
double cover Victor Cruz that single
coverage won't be enough will test your
quarterback because he's so fast and
he's got pretty good hands and we
haven't seen a lot of him obviously but
just from what we've seen in terms of
speed and what it does in the NFL we
know that he's going to need some
attention and so it helps the the Giants
diverse
five their attack they become even more
balanced than they are now because you
know dropping a safety down in the box
who can play the run as well as cover a
tight in it just doesn't apply when you
have that type of speed on the field
Carl from what you've seen can you get a
read on the Eagles at four in one you
really figure out who they are yeah i
think number one they're well-coached
team I think up until I guess the last
two games I thought that they were so
well conditioned that they had a second
gear in the in the third and fourth
quarters like it was almost like they
play these close games please close
games hang in there and all of a sudden
they take off but what they are they're
our team that has to have a running game
that's functioning and that helps the
quarterback out but if they become one
dimensional they're going to struggle
just like every other team in the league
and if you're in it comes down in your
accuracy of your quarterback now would
they have the ability to do though
andrew is win ugly games because of a
guy named Darren Sproles he can get a
tough bird down he can also change a
game for you and special teams and when
you talk about all three phases of a
football team they have that they
address that so you can see where if
you're the Giants who's been
inconsistent at best in their special
teams you've got a number one you got to
focus on protecting your punter because
they blocked a lot of puns this year and
then you got to worry about coverage so
coverage lanes after you protect the
punter then you got to go down there and
got to make sure that your
responsibilities are taking care of
there because Sproles can you know break
one tackle and he's off to the races so
you really have to be four they put a
lot of pressure on every phase of your
team offensively you know they're there
fast-paced offense they want you under
duress so that you can't think you make
bad decisions on the duress so that's
when when they get in a rhythm
offensively the pressure on defense is
not necessarily the assignment but
making the decisions when you're out of
breath you know and that ball is coming
you got to get everybody lined up once
you get lined up what are your
responsibilities once that ball is now
they put a lot of pressure on defenses
that way so I mean that's who they are I
mean they are a well coached team they
cover every phase of it but at the end
of the day it still comes down to you
know can their best players make the
plays to win the football game and we
will find out on Sunday night 830 is the
NBC game it's in Philadelphia the Eagles
and the Giants Carl banks will be there
calling the game on radio for those of
you in New York or listening on the
satellite radio to the Giants feet as he
does every week he's a two-time Super
Bowl champion and he will not be fine
Carl way too nice a call back in thank
you sir for joining us so to have a
great call this week Carl banks
everybody the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience